hear me out before you get upset my name
is Tara chambers and this is the one
year anniversary of cameras never seen
full disclosure almost a full year ago I
think it was going to be my third
episode or so I was going to do
ghostbusters I wanted to tie it in with
the new Ghostbusters reboot or redo or
whatever it technically was Anna
somebody who didn't grow up with the
franchise I honestly was really stoked
for the new one and I didn't really care
about the old ones I'm sorry I was very
scared of backlash and decided to
ultimately scrap that episode the time
it might be a funny thing to bring it's
like my last episode ever but I just
realized a few days back that one year
ago June 25th 2016 Tamra's never seen
Return to Oz was published I've seen
girl know I get a lot of references now
that I never got before I've learned how
to edit more efficiently and shoot more
efficiently thank you for all of the
predictions and all of the suggestions
and all of the good words and all of
those thumbs up we're gonna do it after
the intro plays but I wasn't a huge fan
of it the first time I think now just
hear me out there was a lot of things
going around saying that the new
Ghostbusters all-female saying it was
sexist and I found some sexist moments
in the original Ghostbusters and all my
daughter about how can you say that when
this is you know I was very like up in
the moment so I've given myself a year I
did a whole rewatch I've got my noodle
my all notes and we're just gonna dive
into this I'm gonna tell you what I
think of Ghostbusters finally I'm going
to just hope just like one shot of
tequila though because I'm a little
scared still
[Music]
okay so the cast is incredible obviously
I think the writing is a dates itself a
little bit
the effects are hilarious Sigourney
Weaver can just marry me if she likes so
that's basically the overall hot loot
let's get into it the second scene just
something that bothered me a lot of
first viewing and has to do with the
time that the movie was made it has to
do with the way they just wrote the main
character Bill Murray's character is
kind of a jerk he supposed to be a
lovable jerk and people get into that
but I don't get into that very much I
loved Oh Murray Groundhog Day was one of
my favorite Tambor's never seen episodes
but I don't love his character in bed I
know he's beloved but I think it's like
a Ferris Bueller's Day Off kind of thing
I think he's a jerk and like I don't
want to watch a full movie about a jerk
who gets the girl
that's and we didn't but I was a lot
more upset about Jill Murray the first
time I watched it they go into question
the librarian and he asked if she's on
her menstrual cycle and I wrote Duchenne
80 and then I wrote down okay this is my
tip a little eight I wrote down even
though we all saw the ghost in the
beginning of the movie there will still
be guys defending him for asking if
she's on her mention jock fire y'all
sorry about it but I'm not I'm not sorry
it was obviously a lot more upset about
it the first viewing oh these are my
original notes and I wrote Bernadette
Peters face they're terrible commercial
and immediately experience as a ghost in
her fridge camera it's the Gordie Weaver
girl girl get in together first a year
later and look I'm so much wiser now but
I wrote is that why she's so sick she
can't access her fridge I've always
wanted to make one of those commercials
so like one of those homemade cheesy
poor production commercial hi have you
not seen class
movies like this or this well my name is
Tamara chambers and I'm here to help
[Music]
I also haven't seen classic movies and I
believe that you have it either I love
he gone and Janene I think that they are
the true love story of the age talos
oldest time so Sigourney Weaver comes in
about her refrigerator problem the guys
are like yeah we'll do some research and
stuff and Bill Murray is like yeah no
I'll just go to your house and I'll just
I'll leave some recon there don't worry
I'll come with you to your house alone
let's do it then he doesn't find out
anything it doesn't help anything any
hits on her she's just what she wanted
so helpful keep looking I hate that I
don't like that so the Ghostbusters are
starting to pick up the traction and I
love when they go and capture the ghosts
of the hotel they've ruined the whole
like ballroom and I love love love love
the part where Bill Murray's like wait
wait wait I have always wanted to do
this committee or educate was laughs on
the table it's like super proud of the
flowers are still standing I want to
know if they did that more than one so
here's just like one take and then I
wrote fun fun fun stuff fun Oh ghost
blowjob joke okay moving on so he ends
up getting a date with Sigourney Weaver
and I moved down it's like Ann and Tom
if you've ever seen Parks and Recreation
the character Anne goes out with the
character Tom for a bit and it's like
they just didn't know what to do with
their characters so they made them date
and it doesn't make any sense they're a
terrible couple
it just doesn't work and I just got that
vibe with them McKee starts to warm up
to him and then it starts to work but at
first she's just like I don't like you I
wrote dual the powerful demon God who's
been chilling in a gargoyle for lots of
years breaks loose then I wrote now I'm
on your roof gargoyle and if you get
that reference I am sorry
in my old notes I just have a line that
says and Twinkie so at this point Rick
Moranis is running around and I think
it's pretty funny the gatekeeper
or the key snatcher something he's
wasn't one question though he's throwing
this party and the big dog god guy comes
out and jumps out and everyone at the
party can see it but then he's running
around New York City and he's trying to
get into this restaurant I guess and no
one in the restaurant can see it so why
what Wow
why that was a weird detail but Bill
Murray is having a great conversation
with Jules and mr. Cory Weaver and I
think it's really funny he's had some
really great things like are we still
going out then or just funny dialogue
that really works and and at first
you're like okay and he's taking care of
her he's like treading lightly and then
he like drugs Hearst that she can just
like not visual and if any kisses are
before he leaves and it's like dude come
on that's you can't drag a girl and then
kiss her can't I don't care if it dual
or not I don't care if she Jesus I don't
care if she's a cat just don't do it so
there's like one of the villains in this
movie it's weird you would think it's
the ghost but it's it's this
environmental protection guy who who is
like mad about they're holding
containers for the ghosts and lets all
of the ghosts that they've captured out
doing way more harm than good obviously
and it's like man buddies I bet you
don't get invited to parties very often
I'm really I'm finding through this
second watch that I really enjoy the
characters individually I think
sometimes there's like a bit of a
disconnect for me I felt like minor
characters doing random things and Bill
Murray doing everything but not well but
I wrote the gatekeeper and the keymaster
kiss Wow Sigourney is two for two on
kissing annoying dude they confront
Gozer who's on the roof and he's like
are you gob then died
they love the straight arm action of
that very funny very weird I really
identify with Ray
clear your mind don't think of anything
giant marshmallow man appears
I love Ernie Hudson's line right when
somebody asks if you're a god you say
yes that's just good advice they saved
the city and I love the concept of ghost
hunters I want to be a ghost hunter like
professionally that'd be a blast I love
cats
I love basically everything else and I
must go if you know anything about me
notice all of the GV references that Rob
makes on and off camera will finally
make sense
yes vradi yeah you're still going to
prefer the reboot and your comment
section is going to be a freaking war
zone that's maybe not maybe we don't
have to do that let's just have fun
oh you'll wonder what form you would
have chosen for the destructor I was
thinking that while watching at this
time I think Mike I think probably a
giant Ike you can't decide a Peter
Venkman is cool or creepy
I've decided no you're right I think
there are definite moments of cool I
think he's got some great lines and
really work and I think his character
grew on me definitely over the second
viewing it's really hard to not like
Bill Murray because he's wonderful
you'll wonder if Sigourney Weaver's
husband ever asked her to say there is
no Sigourney only zoom very sexy after
she said that line I said that like a
million times with different people but
there is no ike only zoom no basically i
just did it with ike a bunch of times
there is no i kickin bones chambers
there is only Zuul you'll be shocked
when you realize Venkman brought thirty
cc's of Thorazine the resign Thorazine
the drug to drug to risk to go on his
date with Jana for some reason yeah well
now that you mention it that is odd
I'm really glad reading some of the
predictions that I don't think I'm as
alone as I thought I would be with the
whole sexism thing
oh god I said the word mr. bad word for
the Internet
I'm so amazed that in the course of a
year I watched 51 film that's crazy
that's like more than my whole life I
love love - some of these films and I
didn't love love some of these films and
I love love that I now have opinions on
some films that people love love I love
love it I think for my second year ever
show y'all have to do go sisters - also
I not in my apartment right now but here
you go
bye let me make me feel good
[Music]
[Applause]